[Musique]
cette jeune équipe d'acteurs s'avance
vers la scène et s'apprête à présenter
pour la première fois son spectacle face
à un public
une troupe de comédiens qui a travaillé
sept représentations dans le cadre d'un
atelier chantier d'insertion l'insertion
par le théâtre c'est l'expression de soi
et la confiance retrouvée et cette
capacité à s'extérioriser a retrouvé
confiance en soi c'est très important à
travailler en équipe à retrouver
vraiment confiance en soi c'est c'est
primordial des scènes de la vie
quotidienne sont joués avec comme fil
conducteur les violences conjugales au
quotidien et les différentes formes
d'addiction c'est une thématique qui
s'est imposé tout vient de 1 donc vous
avez envie de nous avez envie de
et de questionner 7,7 difficultés qu'on
a à être en relation avec les autres et
toutes les formes de violence que ça
peut prendre la relation par exemple au
sein du couple dans le travail face à
soi-même face à la rupture sentimentale
c'est des relations quelquefois ces
déchets des choses violentes et puis des
phénomènes d'addiction
moi j'arrête de fumer c'est une scène
sur l'addiction à la cigarette et bah
c'est pour montrer les difficultés à
arrêter c'est vraiment laid toutes les
journées nous le bon et le mauvais côté
en fait de l'esprit qui kidney pour
alain qui nous dit mais il faut arrêter
faut arrêter et puis l'autre qui nous
incite à continuer parce que parce que
c'est bon parce que c'est cool parce que
c'est chouette celles toutes les
difficultés de la fiction d'un sketch
show justement j'étais bien tant que
personnage que sous la rubrique 100
devant la boutique avec ses potes et
quand ils arguaient chedly ben mais il
engueule à peu sa femme
bah c'est pas un peu si le côté macho de
l'homme qu'il faut avoir des parts
égales de la chose pendant une année ces
volontaires inscrits dans une démarche
d'insertion vont travailler leur jeu
d'acteur au théâtre tout en réalisant
leur projet d'insertion professionnelle
de volée de ce chantier d'exception qui
porte ce public
ça nous aide à prendre confiance en eux
aussi moi ça m'a aidé à prendre
confiance en moi chose qu'avant j'avais
pas à vaincre ma timidité
ça nous permet d'être nous même d'aller
au delà de notre capacité de prendre
confiance en nous et de pouvoir le dire
que nous aussi on est capable c'est
vraiment un grand truc parce que comme
ma collègue a dit on n'avait pas
vraiment confiance en nous on avait des
vécu un peu
tous similaires et du coup on sait ça
permet de nous regrouper et de vraiment
donner quelque chose de valorisant cette
troupe se produira tous les jeudis soir
au village corail de saint-paul
partenaires de cette action
les représentations seront forcément
dépendante des contraintes sanitaires
[Musique]